thank you tell you two things both of
which you probably already know first
this is important I am NOT the green
arrow number two photos can be doctored
they could have put Bruce Wayne's head
on that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham
to hang out in Star City recently No
hey everybody new episode of arrow gonna
need you to do me a solid could you just
put on the costume and be the green
arrow from henceforth got a little bit
heat on me so we have to talk about the
big twist at the end but there's a new
round of the Justice League to giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so let's do top 10 WTF comic book Easter
eggs starting with number 10 though is
the shiny new logo if you didn't notice
there are a bunch of Easter eggs in it
but it's way bigger than the previous
logos so it used to just be different
versions of the hose and going back to
season 1 but now like legends of
tomorrow does they have symbols for all
the characters on Team arrow so it goes
black canary wild dog mr. terrific
overwatch guardian in the green arrow
symbol in the Easter Egg within the
Easter Egg is that the symbol order is
based on when you join the team so it
starts with the newest member and ends
with Oliver because he's the oldest
member so number nine we had to talk
about that big Batman name drop which is
crazy that they finally let them do that
they've been doing Batman related stuff
for so many years it was only a matter
of time I think I don't know what the
logic is to when people are allowed to
say things like that
what kind of crazy hoops they had to
jump through before DC and Warner
Brothers was like yeah sure of course
you can totally name drop Bruce Wayne
but that's also sort of the problem with
trying to guess what he's been doing
this whole time because if there's a
Bruce Wayne he's also probably super
rich how come Oliver hasn't mentioned
him before if he's one of the other rich
people in the United States or was one
of the rich people until he lost all his
money so the rule of thumb is that if
you want to get into a debate about this
it's a bit Schrodinger's bat like there
is a Batman there's not a Batman at the
same time until the producers flat-out
come and explain it which they probably
never will and if you're wondering if
Batman can ever come on the TV shows
I'll say probably not while he's still a
billion dollar franchise and especially
not in the
when he has a big movie coming out like
Justice League in a couple weeks so yes
there is a Batman but we're probably
never going to see him and they're not
gonna talk about him a lot
so you may have seen the Gotham people
on their Twitter account making jokes
about this too because effectively
there's about four different versions of
Batman in the multiverse right now
there's the one that will probably debut
with a Titans TV show there's the new
one that Oliver just name-drop there's
one on earth 38 because of Clark's
friend that they talked about on
Supergirl
and then there's the young one on the
Gotham TV show which I think for now we
have to assume is a different earth but
I almost forgot there's actually the
phone from that earth to crossover back
during flash season two so there's a
Bruce on earth - this is implying that
Barry's friends with all of the Justice
League members regardless of what that
team-up looks like on that earth or what
those characters are doing and then you
also have the Queen industries Wayne
merger on the future newspaper on the
flash so because the newspapers dated to
like 2024 we can assume that they might
try to work that in because most of the
big things that they've teased like the
crisis event they've said that they're
actually planning on doing that it's
just that it's so far off in the future
that it's almost not worth talking about
right now until you get name drops like
Batman so we can lay all kinds of
theories about what's going to happen
but arrow would be off the air by that
point meaning they'd have to pay it off
on another TV show like the flash and
that would be the flash season 10 that's
what that date means right there so
that's a long ways off but number 8 we
slide into the broth but plot and we get
a little bit of a follow up from black
cyber and blowing the police station up
that's also a confirmation that that was
the set in real life that they weren't
able to film on anymore so they said
that because logistically it became a
problem they were gonna use it for a
really big explosion in one of the first
episodes but that is what the Bravo want
they want the 20 million dollars Anatoly
wants to buy his honor back effectively
from the large organization because he's
been exiled because of what he did with
all of her last season number six we
meet Samantha Watson who's sort of the
Doakes of arrow now if you didn't watch
the TV show Dexter David Ramsey actually
did an interview recently where he's
like yeah I was on this TV show called
Dexter it was about a serial killer
there was a lieutenant
Doakes that was trying out his identity
through the whole series eventually it
led to his death because by the end of
the series Dexter's identity was still
relatively secret so a lot of you in my
timeline were asking me that well if
lieutenant Doakes ended up dying to
protect Dexter secret what's gonna
happen to this new agent from the FBI
because even though the short-term
answer is as the Diggle will be the
green arrow while Oliver is walking
around talking to her in broad daylight
it sounds like that's probably not going
to stick so at some point she's either
going to have to go away or she'll
become complicit she'll recognize how
he's necessary it just agreed to back
off the way that Quentin did I think
Quentin eventually figured things out
for himself but he could never prove it
like they make that joke about never
having a photograph which we find out
was doctored so number five mr. terrific
and Felicity learned that somebody
created the photo then leaked it to
channel 52 someone from within the
organization and that's where they're
getting all their Intel from or someone
is making it seem like things are coming
from inside channel 52 and that's why I
think this goes back to Michael Emerson
I think that was what most of us thought
after episode one to like oh this feels
like something that he would do his
character is very devious probably a
tech genius just like Felicity so
they've dealt with that for now but we
still haven't seen Michael Emerson in
any of the episodes yet even though he's
been in the trailers so that probably
means he's going to show up in episode 3
and we'll get some kind of taste for
what he's doing the first half of the
season but number 4 mr. terrific and
felicity tease that they're going to go
into business together so I think that's
just the beginning of Smoak technologies
the producer said that they wanted to do
that storyline in previous seasons but
there was too much other stuff happening
and if you don't remember Smoak
technologies is just something that they
learn about in the future of Star City
like felicity eventually in the future
creates her own company
like she just becomes the next big tech
billionaire in Star City but now it
sounds like mr. terrific will be the
hardware man to her software and that's
how they'll bring it together Felicity
made the joke that she would rather go
to iron Heights prison then go back to
tech village that was from the beginning
of season 3 if you remember they had no
money so they all had to get regular
jobs so she started working at their
version of Best Buy which was also sort
a meta joke because Brandon Ralph had
come on the show is Ray Palmer and he
himself had just come from the chuck TV
show that had the buy more so I feel
like that was meant to be a big joke on
that but number three Anatoli kills the
Markovian businessmen cementing himself
as a villain of this season amongst the
other villains that will show up like I
know we all have some expectations for
Richard dragon in Michael Emerson but
Anatoly is just laying his cards on the
table like I'm an honorable man but I'm
still a businessman and I'm gonna do
what I need to do to get back in with
the Bratva
so that'll come back to haunt them but
if you don't remember all the markovia
stuff it goes all the way back to arrow
season one they kind of use it like a
Russian version of corto Maltese where
villains do a lot of business in the
comics markovia is where Tara's family
comes from so that's more Teen Titans so
obviously that show has claimed to those
characters but like way back during
season one Malcolm bought the
Earthshaker from markovia and they also
used it during season five that was
where Kovar was doing some of his
business - when number two was all the
Williams stuff in the episode he had a
pretty good arc it was relatively simple
he just terrified that he's going to
lose Oliver he's going to be alone but
he started the episode wearing all that
flash gear he had one of the coolest
backpacks that I've ever seen on the TV
show and then after all that advice from
Oliver about beating the crap out of
bullies Prison style it's like prison
you know and you punched the biggest guy
the others will leave you alone from
then on to the end of the episode where
he sort of comes around on Oliver he
talks him down a little bit and he's
wearing a green shirt and offers to play
games with him it sounded like they were
playing injustice - so they do this
thing in the episode where they just
played with Williams wardrobe based on
the way he feels about Oliver so when he
comes around he's wearing green like
he's on Team arrow he's on Team dad but
really liking the Williams stuff so far
and then obviously number one is the big
WTF reveal that Diggle will be the green
arrow for at least the next couple of
episodes I'm not expecting it to stick
all season long we've already seen
Stephen Amell fighting during the
crossover episodes in his green arrow
gear against the earth X version of
himself who's the Nazi so we'll see how
that plays out but like he even did a
live stream
on Instagram last night while they were
still filming the episodes with caity
lotz and kyle early from super girl
wearing his green arrow suit so by
episode 8 he'll be back in it but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite moment from the episode yet how
do you think the story with the agent is
going to end will she either die by
someone else's hand because I don't
think that Oliver would kill her or two
do you think she'll learn and then just
back off because she knows that he has
to be the green arrow the city needs him
that bad but either way it was a great
episode it'll be fun to see what things
are like with Diggle being the green
arrow next week but I know a lot of you
been asking for a reverse flash video I
have a QA video for all the DC TV stuff
that I'll post either tomorrow or
Saturday but I'll just name the next
giveaway winner when I post my next DC
video so while you wait for that click
here for that arrow Batman scene again
in the flash trailer and you can click
here from my non-spoilery thor ragnarok
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight